disneyland is cancelling its annual pass  holder program  the main reason the park is worried it  could be overwhelmed by fans when it  reopens after the extended coronavirus  closure ends  imagine disneyland is only allowing 20  000 people in a day  and there are over a million pass  holders plus all the people who are  willing to just buy a single day  admission  the president of the disneyland resort  said because of all the uncertainty  refunds will be issued for eligible pass  holders  it's also urging people not to overwhelm  their phone lines  trying to call for information  disneyland announced that plans are in  the works for replacement program  and will be announced at a later date